nato policy a return to deterrence in
the interview nATO Secretary General
Anders Fogh Rasmussen mr. Rasmussen your
five-year term at the helm of NATO ends
in a couple of weeks time if you strike
your personal balance mission
accomplished at least I'm watching
developments in in Europe putting more
focus on NATO and making it obvious to
everybody that we need a very strong
NATO to provide effective defense
protection of our allies so compared to
five years ago I think we see today a
much stronger fitter faster NATO when
you hand over businesses nato secretary
general to your successor what will you
tell them what is currently the biggest
challenge for native the biggest
challenge will be to reinforce our
collective defense because we are faced
with a dramatically new security
situation in Europe Russia's illegal
military actions in Ukraine are a
wake-up call and a reminder that we
cannot take our security for granted so
the biggest challenge right now is to
keep our line strong to reinforce our
collective defence and that would also
take more investment in our security I
would like to talk a bit more about this
security crisis in Europe five years ago
your key goal was to restore the ties to
Russia the former enemy to re-engage
Russia this was your slogan what went
wrong yeah still I think it was the
right thing to do
actually not only during the last five
years but for more than 20 years we have
tried to engage Russia in a constructive
cooperation and did from my heart I
still believe that the right thing is an
engagement with Russia and basically I
think we share interests in in many
areas but I have to realize that the
Russian thinking is different and though
we decided back in 2010 to develop a
true strategic partnership between NATO
and Russia and Russia doesn't behave as
a partner and we can see from Russian
military document that the Russians
consider NATO an adversary and of course
we have to adapt to that but still I
think it was the right thing to do to
try to engage a Russia but we have to
realize that Russia sees it differently
and we will adapt to that adapting to
the new situation which words would you
use to describe what Russia is now is it
a strategic rival or the new old enemy
definitely not a partner and we see from
the Russian doctrines that they consider
us an adversary but I mean the back in
97 we adopted a joint nato-russia
document called the founding act in that
founding act we stated that we do not
consider each other adversaries and we
will not use force against eat each
other but we have now seen in Ukraine
that Russia is in a blatant breach of
all these fundamental principles so I
think for the foreseeable future we will
have to engage with Russia from a
position of strength and unity and it
was discussing right now what to do in
Crete means are you in favor of
deploying combat troops substantial
troops in countries like Poland or the
three Baltic states and we have made one
thing clear right from the outset that
we stick to the nato-russia founding act
from 1997 and we hope Russia will also
fulfill its commitments within that
founding act having said that I have no
doubt that we need a more visible
presence all over NATO territory
including in on the territory of our
Eastern allies but whatever we do it
will be in compliance with the
nato-russia founding act though Russia
herself has annulled this founding act
of 97 not formally but you're right in
reality Russia has violated the
fundamental principles of the
nato-russia founding act but that
doesn't change our position we are in
favor of a rules-based international
order and also a rules-based security
order in the euro-atlantic area so we
stick to the principles of the
nato-russia founding act and the
measures we are going to take will be in
accordance with this founding act but
NATO's looking that's my impression for
a new long-term approach towards Russia
what do you personally recommend when
you leave office in a few weeks time
should NATO adopt a strategy of
containment em I don't believe in in
containment and I have heard this
Russian suspicion of being encircled by
NATO allies and and and that's really
not a the truth it's not the reality on
the contrary NATO does not constitute a
threat
against Russia I have seen that Russia
considers our open-door policy and
enlargements of NATO as a threat towards
Russia but it's not a threat towards
roster it's based on the fundamental
principle that each and every nation has
the right to decide herself its security
policies and its alliance affiliations
even Russia has subscribed to that
principle and Russia has profited from
enlargements of NATO and the European
Union because thanks to those
enlargement we have created a zone of
stability peace and prosperity in
Eastern and Central Europe and if you
have a look at the trade figures and
investment figures economic figures in
general you will see that Russia has
actually profited from that shown of the
stability and prosperity Western
military experts are still struggling to
find a word for what Russia is doing in
Ukraine right now there's talk of hybrid
warfare or ambiguous warfare what
exactly does that mean yeah it means a
combination of traditional military
measures and more covert military
operations combined with sophisticated
of information and disinformation
operations and that's exactly what we
have seen in Crimea for instance you saw
these so-called green men without
possibility to identify their
nationality so that was a kind of covert
military operation in Crimea which was
supported by a proper as I would say a
true propaganda war and eventually what
I would call a fake referendum and
eventually an illegal annexation of
Crimea
that's a new type of warfare we call it
hybrid warfare because it's a
combination of well-known and new
methods my impression was that NATO was
rather unprepared to this new type of
warfare how come and of course some
lessons have been learned I have to
confess it was a surprise to us that
Russia would violate all the fundamental
principles of the nato-russia founding
documents but also violate its
international commitments and
international law in general we had
expected Russia to respect those
fundamental principles and we have
operated during the last more than 20
years under the assumption that Russia
shared our view that we need a
rules-based international order and
security system but we have to realize
that they think differently and now we
have to adapt to that new situation if
the Russian leadership decided to test
NATO in the Baltic state could they be
defended on the article 5 I can assure
you that we will take all measures
necessary to ensure effective defense of
all allies article 5 in our treaty is
essential it states that an attack on
one would be considered an attack on all
so if any potential aggressor were to
attack a NATO ally all other NATO allies
would help that specific ally and
provides effective defense and
protection finally a brief look
at the ongoing war in Syria and the
onslaught of Isis in Iraq and as well
the Middle East as we know it seems to
be falling apart in how far does this
affect NATO and the Western alliance
potentially it can affect our alliance
in particular our ally Turkey and you
have seen us take the first steps we
have deployed Patriot missiles to Turkey
to ensure effective defense of turkey
against potential missile attacks from
Syria and of course we follow the
situation in the region closely with a
particular view to ensure effective
defense of our ally Turkey nATO
Secretary General Anders Fogh Rasmussen
thank you very much for joining us at
Deutsche Welle you're welcome thank you